Element 105 WME was the shortest video we made at
45 seconds. I know very little about tipping him.
I'm not sure anybody knows much about it.
And I realized there was a lot more to say about it than we did the first time.
And in particular, I have a really nice sample, which is relevant,
which I'll tell you about in a minute.
This is not a sample of top-name, but dope Niamh.
Like all the elements in this part of the periodic table can only be
made synthetically by accelerating a light atom into a
heavier one. And they fuse together. In this case,
the light atom is neon, which has atomic number 10,
and the heavy atom is Amery.
Siham atomic number 95,
10 plus 95 makes 105.
One of the reasons that took Nim is so important in my view
is because there was a huge argument between the first
experiments when it was first synthesized,
which when the early 1970s and the time when it was finally
named,
which was in the late 1990s and really it was
dominium and [inaudible]
, and the arguments about the naming of these elements that really sorted out the really amicable way that we now have of considering the discovery of
this new super heavy elements.
The original experiments were done in a place called [inaudible]
, which Brady and I have visited where the joint Institute for nuclear research is located. This is a big center for accelerators in Russia, and you need, the accelerators took Sellerator up the light
irons to smashing to the heavy target and the difficulties
. You only make these elements one atom at a time. So it isn't as if you have a large lump of the material to analyze. The other problem is they're very short, lived anything from seconds to a few hours. So you can't accumulate a lot of atoms. The way you detect them is that you detect
they
decay. They give out gamma rays, and they also form daughter compounds, which themselves decay. And you can predict with some
accuracy
what energy of gamma rays you would expect. And then quite quickly you get to known radioactive elements so you can work backwards.
The problem is that if you want to synthesize really,
or as stable anatomy as possible,
you need to have as many neutrons as possible in your combined
atom.
The options for making Dupnik element 105 with a large
excess of nutrients is not very great.
So they never managed to synthesize any very stable isotopes.
The difficulty came that's a rival group in America,
in Berkeley, discovered the element at the same time.
And there was a huge argument to priority. We discovered it first,
there was an interesting meeting
between Seaborg and flurry of the leader of the Russian
team. And they tried to resolve this argument, but it was unsuccessful.
And this led to the idea after some considerable argument
of forming a committee that would look at the
evidence from the different teams, an independent committee,
and decide who should take the priority for a particular discovery.
And in the case of dopamine, yum,
it was decided the Berkeley and [inaudible] team had discovered that
more or less at the same time.
The more I wasn't named after two Tupac.
I think there was then a friendly agreement that it should be named after.
[inaudible] not least because Berkeley already had three elements
named in its own, uh, California, Emory SIM, and berkelium.
Plus the ballgame w.
C ball game was named slightly later. But at the same time.
We're a bit of horse trading going on. Do you think, or like, you know,
we'll give you an element if you give us an element.
I suspect,
but it was also complicated because when they finally made the decision,
they also named the elements that had been discovered in dumpster might Nerium
has him and so on. So they were all named more or less simultaneously.
The thing that I think is really remarkable is that although they have made
relatively few atoms of deuterium,
they managed to do a whole series of experiments that can tell you quite a
lot about the chemistry.
Dopamine comes immediately underneath tantalum in the periodic
table.
So you would expect the chemistry of [inaudible] to be really quite
like tantalum,
but it turns out when they did experiments that it was perhaps slightly
more like niobium,
which is the element immediately above tantalum in that group.
These are experiments that are just done with a few atoms.
They're looking at the formation of different sorts of compounds and
how these compounds, for example,
stick to a piece of glass or don't stick to a piece of glass,
or whether if you precipitate them, say with a niobium compound,
does the radioactivity precipitate, or does it stay in solution?
The reason why these things are interesting is because as the
atoms get bigger and heavier,
the relativistic effects caused by the electrons.
Traveling at very high speeds,
lead to the possibility that the periodic table or the periodic
properties may break down.
So it's really quite important that dominium shows the properties of its
own group in the periodic table,
which shows at least a tale element 105,
the periodic properties still behave reasonably,
as one would expect. This sample here is a piece of granite,
sort of red, Russian granite,
which I picked up on the bank of the river Volga,
which flows through the city of Dopner
past the Institute when Brady and I went here.
So I got my piece of granite and my dope enough mug,
which I used for drinking from,
I think the really important lesson from Doug
Niamh is that when it was first synthesized,
there was huge tension between the different groups around the world that were
making these elements.
But now it's realized that as we go further and further
along the periodic table, making heavier and heavier elements,
the only way that we're going to succeed as scientists is if
everybody works together in a collaborative and friendly way.
So I think you should see dominium as the start
of this collaboration, which now has Braden.
I have seen it's really warm between the various groups.
Thank you so much for watching this video and down in the video description,
I'll put links from our trip to Dubna,
along with other videos about super-heavy elements and also about not so heavy
elements. And if you're looking for something different,
why not check out my channel objectivity,
where you can watch videos about historic scientific objects like this and
this and this as well. And more recently,
this video about the history of driverless cars and well,
I'll let you find out about this thing for yourself.
[Inaudible].